THIS SITUATION.
GAYLE?
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ OF FLORIDA IS UNDER
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION OVER A
POSSIBLE SEXUAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH A 17-YEAR-OLD GIRL.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WAS FIRST
TO REPORT THIS INVESTIGATION.
GAETZ IS BEST KNOWN AS A
LOYAL,ARDENT SUPPORTER OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NIKOLE KILLION HAS MORE ON THIS
STORY.
CERTAIN
CERTAINLY THIS IS NOT A HEADLE
ANYONE WANTS TO READ ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
THE CONGRESSMAN IS DENYING THE
ALLEGATIONS, ISN'T HE?
>> Reporter: GAYLE, CONGRESSMAN
GAETZ CALLS THE STORY FALSE AND
SAID HE DID NOT HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH A 17-YEAR-OLD
GIRL.
ACCORDING TO "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS
ARE LOOKING INTO WHETHER THE
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN VIOLATED
FEDERAL SEX TRAFFICKING LAWS BY
ALLEGEDLY HAVING A SEXUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH AN UNDERAGE
GIRL AND PAYING FOR HER TO
TRAVEL WITH HIM.
A FORMER JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL CONFIRMS TO CBS NEWS
THE PROBE BEGAN AT LEAST LAST
SUMMER.
AND FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
BARR WAS AWARE OF IT.
NO CHARGES HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
AGAINST HIM GAETZ.
IN A STATEMENT HE CLAIMS NO PART
OF THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST ME
ARE TRUE.
HE SAID THEY'RE PART OF A LARGER
EXTORTION SCAM TO GET $25
MILLION FROM HIS FAMILY AND
SMEAR HIS NAME.
THE FBI AND DOJ DECLINED TO
COMMENT.
AT LEAST ONE DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKER
IS DEMANDING GAETZ BE REMOVED
FROM THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHICH OVERSEES BOTH
AGENCIES UNTIL THE INVESTIGATI